[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public en étant
centre pour 90 minutes de débat et de
reportage 90 minutes pour donner du sens
à l'actualité grâce à nos invités
experts et voici le sommaire de ceux 22
mai l'offensive de la droite sur
l'immigration les chefs des sénateurs
des députés et du parti LR s'afficher
unis à la une du JDD hier pour proposer
une réforme d'envergure et lancer un
défi à Emmanuel Macron coup politique
contenu des propositions bras de fer et
négociations en perspective on analyse
les conséquences de ce projet dans une
minute et puis dans notre second débat
on relaye un cri d'alarme celui lancé il
y a un mois par quatre associations sur
la famine qui frappe la Corne de
l'Afrique 22 millions de personnes
menacées phénomènes aggravés par les
guerres et le réchauffement climatique
comme l'explique ce pédiatre éthiopien
il y a eu une augmentation du nombre de
jeunes patients des enfants en mal
nourri à cause de la sécheresse nous
rencontrons aussi des mers
contexte que souhaite déposer LR une
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
pour réaffirmer la primauté du droit
national sur le droit européen et ainsi
permettre la convocation d'un référendum
sur l'immigration ce que le droit actuel
ne permet pas pour le gouvernement cette
idée tord de propos c'est inenvisageable
ça signifie que la France en Europe
dirait je participe à la construction
européenne je participe à l'Union
européenne et donc à quelque chose de
communautaire et dans le même temps je
dis que sur tel ou tel sujet il y a
primauté de ma règle sur la règle
commune que nous avons choisie ensemble
avec les partenaires européens c'est le
contraire de la construction européenne
dans un second temps les républicains
déposeront une proposition de loi
ordinaire contenant diverses mesures
reconsidérer un séjour irrégulier sur le
territoire comme un délit pénal ou
encore restreindre l'accès aux soins
pour les sans-papiers LR pourrait aussi
revenir sur le regroupement familial
ah bah le regroupement familial se
stopper clairement il faut arrêter ça
aussi alors on sait très bien qu'il y a
eu des pressions au moment où ça a été
mis en place vers destin par le patronat
français qui fait les mêmes pressions
aujourd'hui pour les sans-papiers et
pour régulariser celles et ceux qui
théoriquement au travail d'une manière
illégale bah il faut résister après
s'être déchiré sur les retraites la
droite voit dans la séquence l'occasion
de présenter un front uni et de profiter
de sa position de groupe pivot à
l'Assemblée nationale faute de majorité
absolue l'exécutif ne pourra se passer
des voies de la droite pour faire passer
son projet de loi immigration
et pour débattre autour de ces deux
textes sur le flux migratoire les flux
migratoires gère la longueur bonsoir
bons souvenirs de la Meuse bienvenue à
vous Emily appelle ski vous êtes
communicantes spécialiste en
communication politique et fondatrice de
l'agence et médico-conseille Jean
garrigue bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue
historien président du comité de
l'histoire parlementaire signal le titre
de votre livre il disait contre Matignon
le couple infernal publié
chez Talandier et Mathieu croissanto
bonsoir Mathis politique Gérard longuel
la situation migratoire de la France
elle nécessite vraiment une nouvelle loi
il faut reprendre le contrôle je
reprends les termes de l'interview de la
triple interview du sujet bonne question
pour moi la priorité c'est la
démographie française qui s'effondre
nous avons 720 000 naissances en 2022 il
y en avait 100 000 de plus il y a
simplement 10 ans en 2012 et ça c'est un
vrai sujet qui rend d'ailleurs
une fraction importante de l'opinion
peut-être même la majoritaire de
l'opinion française assez
réactive craintive sur le thème de
l'immigration nous avons un pays qui n'a
pas confiance en lui-même et qui
s'inquiète de ce qu'il va devenir donc
il y a une question qui est posée vous
pensez que les Français font vraiment le
lien entre les deux thèmes implicite de
la démocratie immigration
quand vous voyez des chefs d'entreprise
qui en effet ne trouve pas de salariés
lorsque vous voyez des écoles qui
ferment parce qu'il y a plus d'enfants
lorsque vous voyez des recrutements qui
sont difficiles parce qu'il y a pas
beaucoup de candidats vous avez un vrai
problème de la démographie française
alors vous
la crainte ou la tentation selon les
points de vue c'est de dire mais c'est
pas grave il y a l'état de gens qui qui
ont besoin de vivre et qui sont prêts à
venir faire le boulot chez vous et c'est
ce débat que manifestement mon président
de groupe Bruno Retailleau Marleix à
l'Assemblée nationale et Éric veulent
ouvrir et c'est important que ce soit
eux qui l'ouvrent je vais vous le dire
pourquoi parce que vous l'avez votre
commentateur la distrait justement nous
sommes le seul groupe qui puisse faire
passer donner une majorité au
gouvernement qui semble être intéressé
par la question sans savoir par quel
boule prendre et le fait que ce soit dit
par marlex et par Retailleau c'est
beaucoup plus important non pas sur le
fond mais parce que il se mettent de
même en situation d'avoir à répondre à
cette question simple que sommes-nous
prêts à accepter que sommes-nous prêts à
abandonner
ça me ferait plaisir que mon Président
débattre dans le cadre du groupe c'est
tout ça viendra oui bah le message est
passé on a bien on a bien entendu alors
on va on va scinder ce débat en quelque
sorte tant de parties on va d'abord
parler de on va dire des enjeux
politiques peut-être du coup politique
puis ensuite on rentrera ça va sans
doute se mélanger mais un peu plus dans
le détail des propositions si vous
voulez bien comment vous analysez et
midi ce couple est-ce que vous dites
bien joué alors je trouve que c'est un
coup de communication oui complètement
et on le voit d'ailleurs dans l'article
de presse avec les trois le trio il y a
un côté comme ça on se montre et on sait
qu'on a l'ascendant puisque c'est grâce
à nous que pourraient être voté un
projet de loi immigration du
gouvernement donc ça pousse le
gouvernement aussi à se dévoiler elle
met au pied du mur par rapport à ce en
même temps qui est très difficile à
tenir sur l'immigration et on l'avait vu
pour le premier projet de loi asile
immigration qui datait de 2018 donc
premier quinquennat qui avait été
complètement vidé de sa substance parce
que une satisfaisait pas assez à gauche
et assez à droite dans le camp macronien
donc quelque part les LR et c'est
justement de dire au gouvernement si
vous voulez aller sur l'immigration il
faut y aller jusqu'au bout moi ce que je
questionne et vous venez d'en parler
c'est les objectifs même si on revient
sur tout ce que vous avez dit moi ça me
parle pas du tout je vois pas de bien
parce que les métiers en tension oui on
sait qu'il y a des il y a des il y a des
immigrés qui font les métiers mais que
aucun Français même vous ajoutez toutes
les naissances possibles ne feraient
parce qu'il considère en tout cas c'est
ce qui se passe et on l'a bien vu
pendant la crise covid je prends juste
la Colette des fraises moi je parle de
la cueillette des fraises au cul aucun
Français de souche je sais pas comment
aujourd'hui
à la crise covid que s'il y avait pas
les mains de des Maghrébins même
temporairement on savait plus faire les
asperges même chose ah oui mais alors
c'est dommage parce qu'on parle de
souverainisme
industrielle agroalimentaire et puis
quand en fait ce que je questionne c'est
c'est le pour moi c'est plus un coup
politique qu'un véritable objet
politique c'est-à-dire que bon les
objectifs sont pas là par contre ça
permet à LR de se positionner et puis
surtout mais c'est un peu triste ça
permet de rassembler les troupes aussi
des républicains parce qu'on a
l'impression que c'est ce qui leur reste
un sujet sur lequel ils sont tous
d'accord y compris des électrons libres
ou trublions comme Aurélien Pradier là
on sait que ça va rassembler
il a fait un peu entendre une voix
par rapport au projet gouvernemental qui
est un projet dont on voit bien qu'il
est il est paralysé parce qu'il est à la
fois et à droite et à gauche et que la
gauche des des de renaissance la gauche
de ce qu'on appelle la macronie et est
hostile au à la radicalisation
durcissement du projet qui est donc une
sensibilité des républicains qui
s'expriment moi je trouve ça je trouve
ça cohérent je c'est en même temps un
coup politique comme l'a dit Émilie mais
finalement ça entre dans une certaine
dans une certaine cohérence après il
faut regarder et on en parlera sans
doute sur le fond de du projet ce qui
est ce qui est présenté ce qui est
réalisable ou ce qui peut apparaître
comme allant un peu notamment la partie
on va dire constitutionnelle de de la
réforme si vous prenez ce qui s'est
passé dans la pré campagne
présidentielle la manière dont Éric
Zemmour appréhendé cette thématique ça
vous montre à la fois que malgré tout ça
n'est pas un thème qui dont les
Françaises désintéressent c'est pas l'un
des thèmes prioritaires il y a le
pouvoir il est passé derrière d'autres
thématiques mais malgré tout c'est un
thème important on le voit depuis 30 ans
on a vu ce que à quel point en 2002
savait jouer son rôle dans ce qui s'est
passé donc c'est c'est un thème
important c'est à mon sens et utile pour
le la vie démocratique que les
républicains expriment leur sensibilité
là-dessus maintenant est-ce que c'est
simplement un coût est-ce que là dedans
il y a vraiment des choses qui sont qui
sont utiles et qui peuvent faire un cap
on peut aussi dire que c'est le début du
négociation
on y reviendra dans un instant mais je
voudrais évidemment qu'on revend là on
l'a vu dans le dans le sujet de de
Jonathan dupriès mais ce qui frappe
c'est d'abord la une du Journal du
dimanche avec donc Bruno otaïo président
du groupe lèvres du Sénat Olivier Le
Marleix le président des députés
ericsiotiques parti alors il y a déjà un
Longuet voilà c'est l'image d'un parti
ressouder c'est on est sorti du
psychodone des retraites c'était c'est
c'est le message qu'il fallait renvoyer
déjà très clairement le sentiment que
j'ai je partage totalement votre opinion
on a des gens de qui partagent en gros
les mêmes convictions et qui en profite
pour le dire et ça clarifie la situation
des républicains aujourd'hui il y a un
projet et finalement la grenade des
goupillé il est donc quand de
renaissance de la majorité
présidentielle est-ce que nous essayons
de faire quelque chose avec eux ou bien
on ne fait rien et donc on ne fera rien
du tout mais est-ce que c'est le seul
thème sur lequel
ces trois-là n'étaient pas divisés non
encore appelé
par la boule rose
il avait pas pu faire lors de la
résidence les républicains souffrent et
là c'est un énorme problème de fiabilité
et de crédibilité et je ne suis pas
certain que leur proposition sur
l'immigration c'est un coup politique on
l'a vu politique à trois bandes pour
ressouder les troupes pour emmerder le
gouvernement et puis et si possible
piétiner sur les plates mais faire
avancer des idées pourquoi pas mais quel
quand même qu'elle paraissent
intellectuelle quand la droite est dans
le tourment elle trouve toujours quelque
chose qu'il a reçu et dans les idées et
dans les idées qu'elle propose elles ne
sont pas franchement nouvelles il y a
rien de révolutionnaire il y a rien de
l'actualité très forte et durable depuis
30 ans dans 30 ans on parle le jeu j'ai
lu dans le texte qu'on parlait
d'assimilation ça me paraît un défi à
ses ambitieux parce que nous avons des
populations qui ont l'intention de venir
pour profiter d'une économie d'un état
de droit les deux sont importants mais
qui ont leur propre culture leur
tradition leur histoire et qui n'ont qui
n'ont en rien l'envie d'abandonner
d'ailleurs il y a un chiffre je reviens
sur la démographie les mariages en deux
gamiques sont très largement
majoritaires dans toutes les populations
immigrées à l'exception peut-être des
Tunisiens qui doivent prendre en dessous
de 50%, mais si vous prenez des
populations turques marocaines ou
algériennes l'endogamie est strictement
majoritaire je parle d'origine je parle
moi je pensais que la France avait le
record des mariages mixtes en Europe
peut-être le record mais un record un
niveau extrêmement faible
je ne crois pas dire de bêtises en
disant que le taux moyen de l'endogamie
pour en tous les cas le Maghreb hors
Tunisie et pour la Turquie c'est plus de
70% donc on a des des communautés qui
vivent entre elles qui vivent bien qui
n'embête personne qui travaille les
Turcs sentir que vous n'avez pas de
bûcherons vous n'avez pas de bon on est
complètement d'accord les gens ne sont
pas là pour voler notre pain mais ils
sont là avec leurs différences qu'ils
assument totalement or dans ce texte et
c'est pour ça que je voudrais le débat
intérieur il y a cette idée
d'assimilation mais c'est quoi
l'assimilation c'est c'est un peu
compliqué pas si facile pas fini vas-y
facile à définir c'est pour ça que
on va débattre et vous allez voir que
c'est beaucoup plus intéressant qu'il
n'y paraît parce que quand on lit
Fourquet on se dit oui l'archetel
français il y a des tas de communauté
pourquoi il y a des tas de communauté
parce que la communauté des
communautarisme des uns suscite le
communautarisme des autres moi je le
vois dans la bourgeoisie parisienne qui
est un peu mon milieu il faut bien le
reconnaître et bien vous avez un respect
les mêmes comportements qui qui court
les filles qui font du sport
que l'assimilation s'est illusoire non
c'est peut-être dans la nature humaine
de ne pas de ne pas se tromper je
voudrais savoir ce que ça veut dire
c'est pour ça que ça
c'est vrai que ces propositions de loi
elles ont beaucoup de choses
intéressantes pas forcément pour
l'immigration mais pour les questions
que ça pose la société mais je dirais
même plus sur les liens avec l'Europe
l'idée de se dire on va retrouver couper
notre souveraineté sur les questions
frontières surtout ces sujets mais juste
se termine les refaire un homme aussi
pourquoi on ferait pas des référendum
sur d'autres sujets que ceux qui sont
prévus par la Constitution donc moi je
trouve que finalement cette proposition
cette proposition de loi sont assez
ingénieuses pas forcément pour traiter
sur l'immigrations et c'est là que je
trouve moi je rejoins exactement ce que
ce que ce que vous disiez c'est que
c'est triste de se dire que les
républicains ne trouvent que cette
thématique avec je vais faire ma petite
féministe trois mâles un peu âgés donc
toujours un peu traditions
[Musique]
dans le monde d'hier qui rattrape qui se
rattrape sur les branches avec un thème
d'hier alors qu'il y a plein d'idées
dedans juste un mot en Europe sur les 27
pays je trouve que vous retrouverez pays
par pays alors en les additionnant c'est
pas les mêmes cas à peu près les mêmes
propositions ou les mêmes réalisations
on a étudié ensemble un séminaire très
intéressant le Danemark la politique
danoise en ce qui concerne l'immigration
elle laisse elle est loin devant
l'objet d'une chronique dans dans
quelques minutes et on fera un focus sur
le Danemark j'en voulais intervenir et
ensuite on reste on revient à la
question un peu plus coût politique ou
pas non sur plusieurs choses d'abord il
y a un mot que j'ai entendu que les
notions de Ko migratoire et ça ça nous
renvoie à la manière dont ce dont ces
débats autour de l'émigration depuis 30
ans son complètement polarisés
hystérisés je devrais pas employer le
mot le terme mystérisé parce que ça
renvoie des choses négatives et en tout
cas je trouve que ça il faut pas jamais
partir de là parce que là on y arrivera
jamais pessimiste mais ça ça fait 30 ans
ou 40 ans que ça dure donc il y a
toujours une polarisation il y a
toujours eu des postures politiques on
est d'accord un thème qu'on peut aborder
sereinement quoi on a une occasion là
justement avec ses projets contre projet
une discussion qui va se faire dans les
groupes parlementaires je l'espère on a
l'occasion de poser un certain nombre de
choses sur la table par exemple de dire
que l'immigration est beaucoup moins
négative pour notre économie que qu'on
ne l'entend très souvent qu'on est
absolument pas nos utilisations de
submersion migratoire pas du tout on est
vraiment y compris par rapport à
d'autres pays européens dans une
situation qui est qui est beaucoup plus
j'allais dire avantageuse que que
d'autres pays tout cela devrait être
rappelé quant à la
constitutionnalisation de plusieurs le
communitarisme enfin la lutte contre le
commutarisme l'assimilation etc
effectivement je trouve que ce sont des
vrais enjeux c'est pas si j'allais dire
c'est pas comment dire ça
archaïque que ça que de poser ces
questions à ces mêmes très très
intéressantes ce que disait un peu
Émilie mais moi je dis que y compris sur
ces questions d'immigration c'est
intéressant de poser ces questions là
qu'est-ce que le communautarisme
qu'est-ce que l'assimilation pour moi
l'assimilation c'est simple c'est de se
conformer aux lois de la République et
aux valeurs de la République mais aux
lois de la République et aux valeurs de
la République ne serait-ce que que
discuter de ça voir de
constitutionnaliser ça comme c'est comme
c'est prévu moi je trouve que c'est
plutôt intéressant alors on va
revenir sur le fond dans un instant mais
je voudrais quand même parler on a d'une
pierre dans le jardin du gouvernement il
y a aussi la question du rassemblement
national qui crie au plagiat à l'image
du député RN du Loiret Thomas ménager il
était ce matin l'invité de France 2 on
l'écoute aujourd'hui
il faut vraiment payer le droit d'auteur
parce que c'est incroyable c'est un
copier-coller quasi mot pour Mou des
propositions de Marine Le Pen Mathieu il
a raison oui pour le oui c'est même
assez incroyable les deux textes que
l'air propose de déposer ressemblent à
s'y méprendre à ce que proposait Marine
Le Pen durant la dernière campagne
présidentielle à la fois dans leur
philosophie je dirais comme dans les
détails des mesures annoncées alors
c'est pas nouveau que on voit des idées
en commun on l'avait vu pendant au ciné
pendant la primaire avec des
propositions de Xavier Bertrand Éric
Ciotti même de Michel Barnier qui avait
déjà montré les dents sur le sujet lors
de cette primaire qui avait été
remportée par Valérie Pécresse mais tout
de même quand on regarde la tenue d'un
référendum sur la politique migratoire
qui était quand même un vieux refrain de
pénis les la franchissement de certaines
règles européennes les demandes d'asile
effectuées depuis l'étranger les
prestations versées au bout de cinq ans
l'aide médicale d'État réduit à une aide
d'urgence vitale le rétablissement du
délit de séjour clandestin ou de la
double peine la facilitéation pardon des
expulsions la restriction du droit du
sol tout ça c'est noir sur blanc dans le
programme de Marine Le Pen 2022 en fait
c'est plus simple de chercher ce qui
diffère ce qui est pas en commun et sur
ce plan moi je que je n'ai trouvé juste
la fixation de quota migratoire par le
Parlement qui pour le coup est une
proposition LR qui n'est pas elle
réclamée
c'est que le LR a un dialogue avec la
majorité présidentielle majoritaire
relative à l'Assemblée mais qui est
quand même la majorité gouvernementale
nous nous avons la faculté de faire
pousser un certain nombre d'idées qui
sont peut-être chez Marine Le Pen mais
qui sont surtout dans tout la dans la
plupart des pays européens qui
s'occupent activement de cette question
parce que contrairement à ce que
l'horloge vous reprendrai sur ce point
c'est un peu compliqué en Suède
aujourd'hui il se pose quand même
vraiment des questions je dis juste que
ce sont des idées en commun dans une
matrice qui est à l'extrême droite de
l'échiquier politique elles sont
partagées par Marine Le Pen par Eric
Zemmour et désormais par les République
par un tiers des pays européens qui sont
confrontés
que si on fait la même chose que les
Danois les Suédois les finlandais je
parle pas des hongroises et là je vous
le conseille ils ont des idées très
arrêtées bon un peu surprenantes parfois
mais pour le reste vous avez des pays
qui sont confrontés à une réalité simple
c'est que la cohésion de l'or système
social n'est pas compatible avec de très
fortes minorités qui sont en marge et en
dehors des comportements habituels de
ces populations alors Mathieu vous nous
dites on reprend le cours de la
chronique moi je pense que c'est c'est
la matrice enfin la pensée sur la
politique migratoire à droite et
désormais commune avec celle de
l'extrême droite
ils peuvent faire pencher la majorité
mais ils choisissent de négocier avec la
majorité présidentielle avec des idées
qui sont celles du parti ils sont les
mêmes ça c'est actuelle que Marine Le
Pen c'est une position de départ
et c'est pas anodin espoir la question
qu'on peut se poser c'est est-ce que
c'est de la triangulation alors la
stratégie politique
alors à la fois il y a sans doute
quelque chose d'idéologique qui est en
commun et puis il y a quand même aussi
une part de triangulation parce que si
ça peut être fixer en même temps Marine
Le Pen c'est pas plus mal mais attention
parce que ce qui pourrait paraître malin
sur le papier revient souvent dans la
figure comme comme un boomerang on le
sait d'abord parce qu'il y a quelque
chose de vrai voilà formule que employé
Jean-Marie Le Pen vous savez les
Français préférant toujours l'original à
la copie alors même si l'histoire
politique est riche d'emprunt en
particulier comme le souligne les gens
tout à l'heure sur ce thème de
l'immigration qui a été très polarisé
très connoté depuis 30 ans c'est c'est
quand même compliqué d'autant que d'un
point de vue tactique reprendre les
idées ou les mots de l'adversaire
revient quand même à lui donner le point
et sur ce plan au-delà de mesures moi ce
sont les formules qui me font les gens
les souligner tout à l'heure quand on
parle de pompe aspirante au cas où
migratoire de submersion d'immigration
de contrôle c'était les mots là encore
effectués mot pour mot des discours du
rassemblement national et puis enfin
parce que beaucoup de ces mesures du RN
qui sont aujourd'hui recyclées par air
pourrait se heurter au mur de la réalité
on y reviendra constitutionnel pas
constitutionnel faisable pas faisable
alors c'est facile de la part d'un parti
qui est un éternel partie d'opposition
comme le rassemblement national c'est
quand même plus surprenant ou moins
compréhensible de la part d'un parti de
gouvernement comme elle est qui n'a pas
non plus résolu le sujet ou les
questions que posent l'immigration en
France quand ils étaient au manche et
puis qui même a dû reculer sur certaines
de ces propositions les plus goûtes
on se souvient en 2007 de la proposition
sur les tests ADN pour pour les
regrouper Jacques Chirac qui a dit des
choses parfaitement contradictoires
entre les odeurs sur le palier à un
certain moment et puis à d'autres
moments la vocation universelle de la
balance bienveillante à l'égard de
toutes les populations vous avez le
client de répondre tout de suite le mur
des réalités je reprends l'expression de
Mathieu à l'instant le ministre Olivier
du socle on va on peut parler de
l'Europe tiens le ministre de Olivier du
socle il était ce matin sur France Info
on en a entendu un extrait dans dans le
sujet d'ouverture tout à l'heure je
reprends cet air ma inenvisageable
contraire de la construction européenne
vous dites que vous êtes
attachés justement à l'Europe ce texte
en l'état je sais bien il va être
discuté négocié il y a la question des
centristes au Sénats qui vont peut-être
présenter leur propre ex bref on est
loin de de pouvoir l'appliquer en France
mais s'il était appliqué ce qui nous met
au banc de l'Europe
la France a vis-à-vis de l'Europe une
attitude qui n'est pas assez attentive
et qui n'est pas assez rigoureuse je
connais un peu l'Allemagne pour avoir
été voisin de l'Allemagne en président
la région Lorraine leur cour suprême
n'acceptent pas nécessairement les
décisions prises au niveau européen par
leur propre gouvernement et donc nous
avons je pense profondément le droit de
faire la même chose mais se pose à ce
moment-là un deuxième problème qui est
évoqué d'ailleurs dans l'article Journal
du Dimanche et implicitement qui est au
fond est-ce que nous n'avons pas en
France un gouvernement des juges et ça
c'est un vrai sujet et moi je suis pas
favorable au référendum pour des raisons
principes parce qu'en général
on exalte les positions les plus
simpliste pour dire les choses gentiment
mais imagine la campagne référendaire
sur ce thème là ce sera dérapage
garantie on imagine on a on a perdu le
référendum sur les institutions
européennes qui étaient pertinent les
institutions je que j'ai pertinent on va
peut-être et on a gagné Maastricht un
1000 poil et on serait bien mal si on
n'avait pas gagné Maastricht en 92 pour
revenir sur le gouvernement de la France
aujourd'hui on a quand même des on a le
problème du pouvoir précédentiel et du
pouvoir législatif c'est quand même un
truc qu'on sait pas vivre moi j'ai connu
deux gouvernements de cohabitation avec
François Mitterrand deux fois d'ailleurs
Jacques Chirac et Baladur c'était très
intéressant on peut faire les deux là on
est dans une cohabitation qui n'avance
pas et qui ne fait rien n'asse un
premier problème et deuxième problème
c'est que la parmi le discrédit des
parlementaires enfin la vie
parlementaire pas des parlementaires
eux-mêmes mais de la vie parlementaire
il y a le sentiment que tout ça n'a pas
beaucoup d'importance parce que en
définitive le juge alors quel qu'il soit
et à des degrés différents va remettre
en cause et au nom de l'environnement au
nom de droit supérieur à la loi au monde
d'accord européen interprété à leur
façon sur sur transposition des
directives on va condamner la France
pour des questions environnementales on
va et là je crois qu'il y a un
rendez-vous qui est un autre à
l'occasion du débat sur l'immigration ce
rendez-vous du du lien enfin de la
relation entre le vote parlementaire
issu du suffrage universel les députés
sont élus au suffrage universel tout
d'ailleurs comme le sénateurs et puis
l'autorité proprio motus du juge qui va
je le pense parfois et même assez de
plus en plus souvent sur le terrain du
législateur parce que sa faculté
d'interprétation est trop grande alors
si on regarde ensemble la partie
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
parce qu'elle est deux la propulsion de
loi constitutionnelle et proposition de
loi on va dire classique ordinaire merci
c'est le terme que je cherchais donc
dans la proposition de la
constitutionnelle possibilité de
référendum sur la politique migratoire
inscription de l'assimilation dans la
Constitution à l'évoquée et possibilité
déroger aux règles européennes et
internationales et effectivement vous
avez repris ces termes qui sont aussi ce
Bruno Retailleau dans le l'interview du
JDD il défend cette réforme
constitutionnelle pour contrer la
révolution juridique silencieuse
Erik sotti lui dit faire sauter les
verrous qui contredisent la volonté
populaire ce que personne n'a osé depuis
40 ans Jean garrix sur cette question là
et je reviens finalement à la question
de la France que au bord de l'Europe ou
comment comment une telle réforme serait
accueillie par nos partenaires européens
c'est une question de cohérence alors de
la même manière que le la question du
référendum sur ces questions mais genre
la longueur a bien dit apparaît comme
absurde parce qu'on sait très bien ce
que ça pourrait donner à quels excès et
à quel polarisation pourrait on pourrait
assister la question de cette de cette
dérogation au traité européen aux droits
européen pose une question fondamentale
de notre adhésion historique à cette à
ce mouvement de l'intégration et de la
construction européenne et or la famille
dit que qui est celle des érections
surtout celle de Gérard Longuet
peut-être plus que qu'avec sauter et
cette famille là elle a été en grande
partie porteuse de cette de ce mouvement
de construction européenne là moi j'y
vois une forme d'incohérence de la même
manière que lorsque je vois les leaders
LR qui qui refusent l'idée du de
l'incitation des à l'immigration pour
les métiers en tension qui fait partie
du programme enfin du projet
gouvernemental j'ai vu aussi une
incohérence parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'à priori c'est quelque chose que même
le simple bon sens pourrait nous on voit
bien le manque de médecin de
professionnels de la santé ou autre
enfin bref là il y a une question de
cohérence alors moi j'espère que dans
les débats qui vont qui vont avoir lieu
vont apparaître les capacités les
possibilités législatives de ces de ces
projets mais pour l'instant je vois par
exemple dans la question dans
l'affirmation constitutionnelle de la
lutte contre le communautarisme au fond
moi j'y vois quelque chose de positif
tout dépend de ce qu'on met sous la
question de communication mais mais là
c'est quelque chose qui me semble
cohérent avec cette pulsion la société
française qui a besoin justement de
combattre cette archipelisation là pour
ces pour pour le référendum ou pour
cette question de la dérogation aux
droits communautaire j'ai un peu de
moyens je trouve que la cohérence elle
s'inscrit dans au fil des années c'est à
dire on pose des questions on peut poser
des questions aujourd'hui sur l'Europe
que peut-être on ne posait pas
auparavant ou qu'on n'osait pas poser je
pense que l'Europe s'est montré par
moment faible ou trop forte vis-à-vis de
nos pouvoirs nationaux c'est pas
complètement incohérent que ça vienne
des républicains ou d'ailleurs qu'on
lève ce tabou de pouvoir critiquer
l'Europe et ce qu'elle nous impose
parfois après je suis pas sûr que ça
soit sur la question migratoire que ça
soit le plus efficace parce que on sait
que quand même il y a un niveau européen
sur lequel on pourrait jouer pour la
question migratoire qui serait bien plus
efficace mais par contre encore une fois
je trouve que cette proposition de loi
ce serait tous au film migration elle
elle pose des questions remettre en
question le pouvoir de l'Europe c'est
pas complètement
idiot et c'est vrai que l'Allemagne a
toujours pris des libertés aussi parce
que probablement elle avait elle
bénéficiait d'un certain pouvoir dans
l'Union européenne que la France n'a pas
et je pense que c'est bien et pour
revenir sur le référendum évidemment
qu'on sait que c'est caricatural la
plupart du temps les réponses mais
l'idée de faire participer les
populations aux décisions publiques
c'est justement ce qui est en jeu
aujourd'hui depuis le 49.3 de la réforme
des retraites alors peut-être que c'est
pas le référendum mais ça serait bien
que ça soit je reprends la main parce
que je l'ai promis tout à l'heure étant
affiler on va parler tout de suite du
modèle danois auquel vous soyez faisiez
référence grâce à Steve jour d'un qui
doit être juste derrière il se cache
dans le rideau bonsoir Steve bienvenue à
vous alors il est de plus en plus cité
par les hommes politiques français ils
font politique d'ailleurs de droite
comme de gauche
c'est ce que vous allez nous démontrer
oui être ou ne pas être danois tel
devient un peu la question dans le débat
politique français ces dernières
semaines écoutées
regardez le Danemark le Danemark
pourtant ce sont des sociaux-démocrates
un tour de vis sans précédent disruptif
la rupture eux ils ont fait la rupture
la rupture que je demande voit sur
l'immigration et bien eux ils l'ont fait
je rencontre ici à Copenhague les
responsables de la classe politique
danoise notamment les sociaux-démocrates
qui sont au pouvoir pour pouvoir
comprendre comment cette ce centre
gauche est social-démocratie à la
danoise a opéré une mutation idéologique
assez importante que l'a permis de
mettre au tapis l'extrême droite alors
cette politique elle serait à mon avis
énormément critiqué en France à peu près
toutes parts Olivier Véran et
théodanemark un début mai demain ça sera
au tour d'érections d'embarquer pour
Copenhague voyage de deux jours avec une
délégation d'élus pour s'inspirer des
politiques migratoires du pays ça c'est
pour la droite et le gouvernement mais à
gauche aussi Thomas on observe de presse
ce qu'il se passe au Danemark on va voir
cette note de la Fondation Jean Jaurès
en date de début janvier voici ce qu'on
peut y lire la sociale démocratie
danoises a été confrontée à la même
problématique que la France et que
d'ailleurs toutes les familles de gauche
européenne mais la stratégie a été très
différente ni celle de l'autruche ni
celle du caméléon le modèle danois
constitue une réponse originale à un
problème que la gauche ne parvient pas à
résoudre alors comment le Danemark
a-t-il résolu ou tenté de résoudre cette
question migratoire par la méthode forte
voire très forte on va voir quelques
mesures adopter là-bas elle est
candidats à l'immigration sont l'objet
d'une confiscation de leur bien argent
aux bijoux l'idée c'est notamment de
couvrir les frais d'hébergement et de
procédures ils doivent aussi prouver
qu'ils peuvent subvenir eux-mêmes à
leurs besoins en attendant d'être
régularisé ils doivent maîtriser la
langue il y a également des tests sur
l'histoire et le fonctionnement de la
société danoise ils n'ont pas le droit
de s'installer dans certains quartiers
l'objectif déclaré du gouvernement c'est
d'éviter la constitution de ghetto
urbain dans ces mêmes quartiers les
sanctions pénales sont renforcées pour
les habitants par rapport au reste du
territoire et puis à la question de
l'obtention des papiers avec pas mal
d'obstacles qui sont dressés oui avec
l'idée de rendre très restrictive les
conditions de l'obtention de la
citoyenneté quand il est accordé par
exemple l'asile politique et la plupart
du temps provisoire même pour les
Syriens qui ont échappé aux griffes de
Bachar al-Assad plus généralement quand
ils sont déjà sur le territoire il faut
savoir que les immigrés ne peuvent pas
obtenir de régularisation pendant 4 ans
et demi en cas d'infraction supérieure à
400 euros ils font également face à un
blocage définitif de l'accès à la
nationalité en cas de peine de présence
qui est étonnant un vue de France c'est
que Danemark se mesure font largement
consensus et que c'est la gauche qui
depuis 2016 les a encouragés et mis en
oeuvre merci Steve Jourdain Mathieu
tiens je me tourne vers vous est-ce
qu'il y a il y a pas une gauche
française en retard d'une d'une réforme
sur ces questions là la gauche française
a toujours ce que c'est un c'est une sur
des mesures mises en place
française depuis longtemps parce que
pour pour déviser j'ai été
internationaliste et puis mon dévisé
électoralistes il y a les deux il y a la
fois la tradition de la gauche qui veut
que la France est incrusée ou se mélange
des nations des citoyens des ouvriers
mais pas forcément des des citoyens de
nationaux enfin on peut voir on a une
tradition de terre d'accueil je vais
dire pour simplifier et puis et puis il
y a eu des préoccupations aussi
électoralistes qui étaient de considérer
que de toute façon la gauche ayant perdu
les ouvriers ça avait été théorisé par
une note de l'Institut Terra Nova vous
en souvenez qui a été beaucoup parlé et
bien la gauche devait se tourner
maintenant vers notamment les immigrés
et descendants d'immigrés qui pouvaient
constituer une armée de réserve en gros
en terme en termes de voie ce qu'il a
d'ailleurs jamais été vérifié mais voilà
la gauche qui traditionnellement se dit
du côté des opprimés a longtemps
considéré que l'immigré était opprimé et
voilà pourquoi après une fois aux
manches et ben la gauche à part Lionel
Jospin qui avait fait cette grande
régularisation qui lui a été reproché
parce que ils considérait qu'il y avait
trop de de sans papiers et que il
fallait c'était sans papier qui était
soit installés dans la société française
qui travaille et qui payait dans un pot
qui avait des enfants à l'école qu'il
fallait régulariser comme
un peu atténuée mais elle a été
démontrée par plusieurs associations
années après année donc oui mais j'avoue
déjà peut-être vous choquer mais c'est
pas complètement ta normal c'est plus
facile de discuter avec quelqu'un qui a
été dans la même école que vous qui a
supporté le même club de foot qui a eu
les mêmes passions au cinéma avec Gabin
ou avec plus récemment trouvez-moi une
jeune femme
quand on a grandi en banlieue dans une
cité où il y avait la tentation de la
délinquance du trafic de drogue je
schématise mais pas seulement et qu'on a
décidé de faire des études d'avoir des
diplômes et qu'on se dit refuser un
poste équivalent à un logement pour un
logement parce qu'on s'appelle
il peut s'appeler pierre vous savez
c'est un prénom qui est très bien porté
depuis très longtemps
c'est pas un problème d'ailleurs il y a
un truc qui change de prénom pour
pouvoir être embauché
chez moi en Lorraine il y a 10 %
et il s'appelait tous Jules André ou
maintenant il s'appelait Enzo donc il y
a un retour
je vous assure il y a des noms assez
forts
américaines
Émilie et ensuite moi ce que je trouve
intéressant encore une fois dans les
propositions des Danois c'est de lever
des tabous en effet de parler des
ghettos qui ont poussé en effet aux
communautarisme parce que des gens qui
sont parqués dans des endroits
vous allez voir votre cousin et le
cousin d'hygiène de la place dans la
chambre et vous restez dans le collège
public donc on les met tous ensemble
parce qu'ils ont envie parce que les
plus riches ont envie d'aller dans le
privé puisqu'il va surtout pas se
mélanger
l'éducation nationale j'ai regardé dans
le 18e des collèges et bien il y avait
le la frontière entre les bobos et les
immigrés d'origine parce que les
immigrés étaient plus anciens que les
bobos dans le 18e donc les les immigrés
étaient déjà dans le collège ils ont et
il y a eu une scission entre les enfants
de bobos et les enfants d'immigrés dans
les collèges différents c'est pourquoi
parce que vous avez des enfants et quand
on a un enfant on y tient tellement
convenu donner toutes les chances c'est
quand même que ça se passe
en effet
les francophones sont minoritaires vous
commencez à faire des bas sur la mixité
sociale à l'école effectivement
c'est pour ça c'est fait c'est pour ça
mais c'est pour ça qu'à mon sens ce qui
est intéressant dans ces débats c'est ce
qui concerne justement le
communautarisme et l'assimilation
essentiellement assimilation auquel on
pourrait associer le mot d'intégration
aussi parce que le problème n'est pas
celui de l'immigration de la submersion
migratoire des flux migratoires etc le
vrai problème c'est comment on intègre
ces populations et au passage c'est un
problème qui ne se résoudra pas à
l'échelle nationale c'est pour ça que je
suis embêté par cette idée de déroger au
droit européen ce sont des enjeux
européens c'est presque même des enjeux
mondiaux mais en tout cas à tout le
monde les enjeux européens et l'enjeu de
l'assimilation et des fondamental mais
il mérite évidemment d'être discuter de
manière extrêmement
parfois précise nuancer pondéré et pas
en s'envoyant comme ça comme on l'a fait
depuis 30 ans des anatomes toi tu es toi
tu es un raciste et toi au contraire tu
es un laxiste et on est dans des des
vous dites c'est au niveau européen ou
peut-être même au niveau mondial que ça
doit se régler ça fait le lien avec ce
qui sera notre second thème de de débat
puisque dans quelques minutes on va
parler de cette famine historique qui
s'abat sur la corde de l'Afrique Gérard
Longuet est-ce que c'est pas illusoire
de vouloir dresser des murs législatifs
et constitutionnel autour de notre riche
Europe quand voilà la sécheresse la
famine pousse des millions de personnes
vers le vers le nord
la démographie pousse des millions de
personnes vers le nord là c'est les
chocs démographique qui conduisent les
grands mouvements de population vous n'y
échapperez pas pourquoi
il n'était pas européen et il n'était
pas ni chrétiens ni juifs ils étaient
indiens sauf que la démographie a parlé
et mal oui mais vous répondez pas tout à
fait à ma question
la vraie c'est pour ça que je suis tout
à fait multilain pour les organisations
multilatérales et le respect des accords
internationaux pourquoi parce que on est
quand même en train de construire un
Ordre Mondial à peu près réfléchi et je
pense que quant à la
crise en Éthiopie elle est affreuse s'il
y avait un peu moins de guerre civile
antigrées
j'ai fait la connaissance de Claude
malurey quand il s'occupait de mes seins
sont frontières on est justement et nous
investissions avec Alain Madelin et avec
Michel Sapin on est on a vu le travail
formidable que vous aimez 500 frontières
mais je me suis rendu compte aussi que
les problèmes n'étaient pas
infirmontable techniquement et
matériellement mais que la société était
structurellement indifférente au
malheurs des uns ou des autres dès lors
qu'ils n'étaient pas directement
concernés société éthiopienne on l'a vu
avec les derniers puisqu'on a accepté
des réfugiés des familles ont accepté
les réfugiés mais c'est il l'a dignité
de l'Europe vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine je ne
sais pas quel sera l'issue de cette
guerre mais je trouve que les Européens
ont une attitude digne et dans l'accueil
et nous soutien mais on peut pas faire
de différence entre les types d'origine
quand on parle à peu près des mêmes
références on aura compris les arguments
des uns et les autres merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce premier débat
dans sens public